- "Halloween 5" is a movie
that raises more questions than answers,
but it answers at least one
thing I was wondering about,
but probably nobody else
cared about in "Halloween 4".
Number five would be "The
Revenge of Michael Myers",
and the opening is a
continuation of the ending of 4,
where Michael was shot
repeatedly and falls into a hole.
Here we see what happened next,
which may be a little
nod to how "Halloween II"
handled its intro and
wouldn't be the only one.
Michael escapes through this tunnel
to make it to a river
where he floats downstream to escape.
I'm reminded of this line
from Reverend Jackson Sayer,
who gives Dr. Loomis a lift
early on in "Halloween 4".
Many of his lines fit in
with the theme of fate
seen in that movie, which
you can hear all about
in the previous episode
of Things You Missed.
But there are a couple that
just seem like weird lines,
like this one.
- I saw it on your face
back there in the dust.
I saw it clear as breasts
in blue suede shoes.
- Which I still don't really understand,
but there's also this hymn that he sings
at the end of his scene.
- ♪ Yes, we'll gather at the river ♪
♪ The beautiful, beautiful river ♪
- Could this have been a foreshadowing
that Michael's supposed fate
was going to be in this river?
Whatever the plans were for "Halloween 4",
it's pretty clear that the
next sequel changed them.
To learn how "Halloween 5"
attempted to honor its
predecessors (somewhat poorly),
stick around to the end of this video.
(dark music)
"Halloween 5" would, as always,
not bring back the
previous movie's director,
in this case, Dwight Little,
who seemingly just wanted
to quit while he was ahead.
To pronounce the new director's name,
I give you Halloween expert and Frenchman,
Jimmy Champane.
- Dominique Othenin-Girard
is the correct pronunciation,
and despite the fact that
my last name is Champane,
I'm not actually from France.
I did a video on "Halloween
5" a few years ago,
and I had to learn exactly
how to say that name.
When I saw "Halloween
4" for the first time
and specifically how it
ended, it really affected me
because I was the same age as Jamie,
and I really wanted her to win.
But over the years and
after seeing "Halloween 5"
and where the story went from there,
I think it actually could
have been kind of cool
to see Jamie take up the knife and mask.
If you think about it though,
it's absolutely insane that this ending
was green-lit in the first place,
because the only reason
"Halloween 4" exists
is because people were so mad
that Michael Myers was
killed off in "Halloween II"
and then not featured in "Halloween III".
The point I'm trying to make is that
as the Halloween franchise went on,
there was a clear divide
between the producers,
the filmmakers and the fans,
and this movie suffers the
most out of any of them for it.
- To try to change things up a little bit,
(I guess) Girard tries to
humanize Michael Myers,
which kind of defeats the
point of Michael Myers.
- Calling the mask in "Halloween 5" a mess
would be the understatement of the year,
but it's actually pretty interesting
that it was sculpted by Greg Nicotero
of "The Walking Dead"
and "Creepshow" fame.
I've always struggled to understand why
instead of using the mask from
"Halloween 4" in this movie,
because that movie's ending
bleeds directly into this movie's,
they just sculpted a new one
after Greg Nicotero's head,
which is why it has a teardrop shape
and looked completely
different than any other mask
in the franchise.
- I don't really know
what his motivation was
for making a character so
well-known and well-stated
to be inhuman seemed more humanized.
It sounds like he just has
this weird crush on The Shape.
- Such a vulnerable little girl
against a massive, amazing
strong man who nothing stops
when he has an idea in his mind.
He just goes straight.
- But something tells me you don't.
That being said, we've talked
about the first four movies,
so we might as well do these ones.
Let's get into the things you missed.
(eerie music, knives slicing)
I'll actually admit that
the opening title sequence
to "Halloween 5" is a little bit creative.
In one and two, we see a pumpkin
over a black screen with the credits.
In three, we see the credits play
over this digital display of a pumpkin
to fit the sci-fi/horror
genre of that movie.
And in four, we just see
more of a pumpkin patch
and some other stuff.
So five kind of reinvents that concept
by cutting in quick slices of a pumpkin
being massacred by a knife,
some of which are shot
from inside the pumpkin.
This would be the movie
where we really go inside Michael Myers
for better or for worse.
- I'm gonna go with better.
No, worse, it's definitely worse.
- As I mentioned, Michael
escapes his hunters
by letting the river carry him downstream,
where he meets a hobo
and his pet bird, Tippi.
- There's nothing out there, Tippi.
- In our "Halloween" 1 video,
we talked about how characters
like Loomis, Marion and Leigh
were all named after characters
from Alfred Hitchcock's
classic horror film, "Psycho".
For this reason, I
think Tippi may be named
after the actress that debuted
in Alfred Hitchcock's
"The Birds", Tippi Hedrin.
- Anyway, a year has gone by
and Jamie is still
regularly having nightmares
about her uncle, and she's also gone mute
as part of the trauma she
experienced last Halloween.
This is a very heavy-handed sign
that she's connected to Michael,
and that her visions are actually her
seeing through The Shape's eyes.
But looking back, this
is also definitely part
of the director's attempt
to humanize Michael Myers,
which was like his main
goal going into this movie.
I don't know if you guys knew that.
I mean, if I was making the
middle movie in a trilogy
five movies into a franchise,
that's about when I would switch things up
and completely change the
motivations of the main villain.
In the last movie, Jamie
is one of the survivors.
She's who we empathize with.
She's who we're rooting for
through the entire thing.
Michael Myers doesn't
talk, now she doesn't talk.
It's how we relate to
him a little bit better.
I don't really think it
makes a lot of sense.
- Last year, Jamie wore a clown costume
just as Michael had many years ago,
but this year she goes as a princess.
You may remember the
princess in clown drawings
on her door in "Halloween 4",
so this choice represents the idea
that she's now going down the good path
rather than the evil one.
However, she can't fully get
rid of the clown and the evil.
She still has dreams about that night.
The care facility that she's staying in
is decorated with items
like a balloon-themed lamp,
this clown light switch, a
clown-themed height chart,
and this absolutely comforting clown
placed in her room to watch her sleep.
We also see a clown doll at her home,
even though she never
goes there in this movie.
You would think maybe the
people taking care of her
would put all of this clown stuff away
to avoid bringing back those bad memories,
but it seems they've just opted for the
get-over-it-sooner-rather-than-later
approach.
The other survivor is
Rachel, her adoptive sister.
She gets home to get ready
for a Halloween party.
(phone rings)
- Ugh, I'm coming.
- Why does she yell "I'm coming"
as she's running to the phone?
Like, she does realize
the caller can't hear her
until after she picks
up the receiver, right?
- Can someone give me one good reason
why they decided to do Rachel so dirty?
She was one of the best characters.
- Loomis warns her to
get out of the house,
and then she's just out of breath
upon reaching the edge
of her own property.
Time to hit the cardio, Rachel.
At this point, the cops show up
accompanied by circus
music for some reason.
(silly squeaking music)
And no, we didn't add that.
That's just the music that's in the movie.
(silly squeaking music)
- It honestly took me years of rewatches
to notice this music that
plays underneath the cops.
There is so much bizarre shit
going on in "Halloween 5"
that it didn't even
register as weird to me.
- At this point, we start to see Michael
acting differently than
he has in other movies,
but he would not be the only one.
(dark music, thunder rumbles)
(eerie music)
- In the original "Halloween" movies,
Michael Myers is shown to
be this unstoppable force.
He stalks and comes
after his victim slowly
and he shows no mercy.
In this one, there are multiple points
where he doesn't kill a victim
even though he has a clear chance to,
and I've thought about
this a lot over the years,
and the only explanation
I can come up with
is that this is yet
another shallow attempt
to humanize Michael Myers.
For example, he sees Rachel in the house,
he puts his hand on
the clothing rack here,
and instead of doing anything about it,
he just walks out of the room right after.
What happened there?
Did he leave his Viagra in the car?
Something similar happens
as he watches Sammy and Tina
outside the hospital later that day,
but doesn't make his move.
Then later on, once the killing has begun,
he finds himself behind the
wheel of a large automobile.
We all know that Michael Myers walks slow
because that's part of his character.
It's been established from the beginning.
But is there any reason he
has to drive slow as well?
The only logical explanation
is that he's taking time
to enjoy stalking his victims.
The corpse shrine he builds in
the attic of the Myers house,
which by the way, is completely different
than the one we've seen
in the other movies
suggest that there's an art to the way
that Michael Myers does his killing.
That, along with when he stops his rampage
to listen to Loomis tell him
how he might be able to cure his rage,
and then again, when Jamie calls him uncle
are clear signs that maybe he does have
a human side after all.
And that's when they take it too far
by making this bad-ass
slasher start crying.
- Michael is not the only one to undergo
a change in behavior in this movie.
If he's becoming more human,
I think maybe Dr. Loomis
is becoming less human.
Billy is a fellow patient
at Jamie's clinic,
and I think they bond
over their speech issues.
He has a stutter and she's
unable to speak at all anymore.
When little Billy comes
in to check on Jamie
and see if she's okay,
Loomis just ushers him out
and slams the door on him.
- Slam!
- The way that he talks to Jamie
is perhaps the scariest
part of this movie.
(crashing)
- What about your stepmother, Jamie?
(Zac laughs)
- What?
- Then he also tells Jamie that Michael
dug up the corpse of a nine-year-old girl,
which we never see happen,
so did he just make that up to scare her?
(creepy laughing)
And then the finale,
without telling her the plan or anything,
he just offers her up to Michael.
- You want her?
Here she is.
- [Zac] No disrespect to Donald Pleasence,
but Loomis should just
be shot at this point.
Now I only noticed one
crew reference easter egg,
and that is the badge of
this police officer Markland,
which references the prop
master in "Halloween 5",
Sean E. Markland.
However, there were also some callbacks
to other "Halloween" movies.
So let's just start with "Halloween" 1.
- I like that movie,
so I'll take this one.
There are a ton of
references to mundane details
in the original movie,
like this conversation
between Sammy and Tina.
- [Tina] Sammy, why don't
you bag Spitz tonight?
- [Sammy] I couldn't do that.
- Oh, sure you could.
- Oh, no I can't.
- [Jimmy] Which is essentially
the same conversation
that Annie and Laurie have in the car.
- Sure you could, all you have to do
is go up to somebody and say,
"You want to go to the dance?"
- You could do that, I couldn't.
- The way that Michael slams on the brakes
when Tina asks him to
stop at the gas station
is eerily reminiscent
of exactly what he does
in "Halloween" 1.
The way that Jamie sees Michael
standing outside her window
is also exactly how Laurie
sees him outside her window
in "Halloween" 1.
And then of course, there's a scene
where Jamie is chased
through clothes lines
which have large sheets hanging on them.
That's something we talked about
in the videos for "Halloween" 1 and 2,
and it's actually great
to see that this movie
is going back to basics by
making most of the victims
teenagers who want to get laid.
- [Tina] You guys wanna
come skinny dipping?
- Are you serious, Tina?
This is the same chick who
just got done complaining
that it was too cold
standing outside the car
for two seconds.
Now she wants to go skinny
dipping in Illinois in October?
There are also a couple of similarities
to "Halloween II" and
"Halloween 4" in this one,
like the false scare involving someone
dressed up as Michael Myers.
We've also seen several
examples of the opposite,
where Michael is disguised
as one of the regular human characters.
This time, it's another guy
who happens to be named Michael.
- Michael, open the door.
- The movie also brings back
the "Halloween 4" concept
of Jamie riding on someone's
back to escape out a window,
and continues the tradition
from "Halloween" 1 and 4
of taking out a dog very early on.
When we see the shrine of all
of his victims in the attic
and Jamie sees the dog,
it still barks somehow.
Also half the jump scares in this movie
are from animals.
(screams)
I do not know how there's
just like a picture
of Coraline's mom right here,
or how Dr. Disrespect manages
to show up on a wanted poster.
I do not know why there's
this weird jump cut
when Mikey is getting jumped by Michael.
I do not know why this lady
looks directly at the camera,
and I do not know why the
end credits feel the need
to specify that the names
represent the cast of characters
as if we've never seen a movie before.
- And also real quick,
did they think we wouldn't
notice that this is dubbed?
- We just had a distress
call from the clinic.
They haven't been able
to reach them again.
There were four men up there.
- There is one character that
we have not mentioned yet,
and that is... Moleman.
No, I'm talking about Dr. Terence Wynn
who is basically just an
unsolved mystery in this movie,
but would return in the next movie,
"The Curse of Michael Myers".
As the name implies, Michael
Myers will also be returning
in the sixth movie,
which would be the last
of what is now called
"The Thorn Trilogy".
What I will about the cult of Thorn
is it would have been
cool if its introduction
opened up the series to more
powerful and evil entities
outside of just The Shape.
So naturally, as with
the ideas of Halloween
being an anthology franchise
and Jamie being an antagonist,
that is not what happened.
But before we venture forward
to the end of "Halloween's"
original timeline,
make sure you grab your
baret, bake your baguette
and head on over to the
wonderful channel of Champane.
- [Jimmy] If you haven't
checked it out yet,
there's rankings, short films
and tons of other videos to dig through.
So remember to subscribe to CZsWorld
for new horrors every week,
ring the death bell for all notifications,
and we'll see you in the next
one, assuming we both survive.
- Did you just steal my line?
Okay, change of plans.
Jimmy will not be joining
us in the next vide--